>> ♪ ♪
>> IN 2 HOURS PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL HOLD A HOMECOMING RALLY IN
THE BATTLEGROUND STATE OF
FLORIDA TO CELEBRATE HIS
OFFICIAL MOVE FROM NEW YORK CITY
TO THE SUNSHINE STATE.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG'S TEAM IS
WARNING DEMOCRATS THAT TRUMP IS
WELL POSITIONED TO WIN
REELECTION.
>> MIKE IS GETTING IN THE RACE
BECAUSE HE THINKS DONALD TRUMP
IS ON THE PATH TO VICTORY.
RIGHT NOW DONALD TRUMP IS
WINNING.
IT'S TOUGH FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT THAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> AND A NEW REPORT SAID FORMER
OBAMA IS PRIVATELY CRITICAL OF
JOE BIDEN AND TELLING A
CANDIDATE THAT BIDEN DOESN'T
HAVE IT WHEN IT COMES TO
ESTABLISHING A BOND WITH THE
ELECTORATE IN IOWA.
>> IT DOESN'T TAKE A BRAIN
SURGEON TO FIGURE ON THOUGHT.
I SAID THAT FOR A YEAR.
JUST LOOK AT HIM ON TELEIVATION.
THERE IS NO BIDEN BASE -- NO
BIDEN MOVEMENT.
THERE IS NOTHING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE HAVE TO
LOOK AT POLLS AND WORRY ABOUT
JOE BIDEN BEATING DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
EVEN THE GUY THAT PICKED HIM TO
BE THE VICE-PRESIDENT AND SPENT
8 YEARS WITH HIM KNOWS IT WILL
NEVER HAPPEN.
FORGET ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
HE IS OVER-RATED.
THE ONLY PERSON MORE OVER-RATED
IS BLOOMBERG.
SO WHAT IF HE HAS MONEY?
HE WON'T WIN SINGLE STATE.
ALL OF THE ADVERTISING HE DROPS
ON TRUMP WILL BACK FIRE.
TRUMP IS GETTING ATTACKED BY A
SHORT BILLIONAIRE FROM NEW YORK
CITY.
>> WHAT IS WRONG WITH WITH
SHORT.
>> YOU BETTER REVISE THAT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT WILL STRENGTHEN TRUMP.
>> 30 YEARS FROM NOW I WILL
DRUDGE UP THIS TAPE AND YOU WILL
BE CANCELLED.
>> DANA, IT'S INTERESTING.
YOU HEAR THAT BLOOMBERG'S
CAMPAIGN MANAGER SAYING DONALD
TRUMP IS WINNING.
BUT WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
INCUMBENT WOULD HAVE AN
ADVANTAGE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
BIDEN IS BEATING TRUMP BY 10.
AND WARREN BY 6 AND SANDERS BY
7.
>> IT COULD BE TRUE IN THE
POPULAR VOTE BUT NOT TRUE IN THE
BATTLEGROUND.
WE SAW THE NUMBERS FROM
WISCONSIN AND THAT WAS GOOD NEWS
FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
FLORIDA IS WHERE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS ARE DECIDED.
THE PRESIDENT MOVED FROM NEW
YORK TO FLORIDA.
BLOOMBERG HAS A SOLID BASE OF
SUPPORT IN VIRGINIA BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE MONEY HE PUT IN TO
THIS TO GET DEMOCRATS ELECTED ON
GUN ISSUES AND ON CLIMATE CHANGE
AS WELL.
THE THING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND VICE-PRESIDENT PENCE AND
PRESIDENT OBAMA -- SORRY, TRUMP,
BLOOMBERG AND OBAMA ALL AGREE
THAT BIDEN WON'T BE THE NOMINEE
AND HE CAN'T BE TRUMP.
>> THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT
OBAMA IS SAYING?
>> I THINK THERE ARE WORRIES
FROM OBAMA THAT BIDEN WON'T BE
ABLE TO WIN THE PRESIDENCY EVEN
IF HE GETS THE NOMINATION.
GOING BACK TO PRESIDENT OBAMA
SAYING YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
JOE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO A BIG
GROUNDSWELL OF SUPPORT.
IF BIDEN WAS RUNNING IT AWAY
THIS, WE WOULD ALL KNOW IT.
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO RAISE THE
MONEY.
THERE IS NO GROUNDSWELL OF
SUPPORT.
IS THIS A POINT WHERE BIDEN WILL
SAY I WILL PUT ALL OF THESE
TOGETHER FOR ME.
THE ONLY WAY IS IF PRESIDENT
OBAMA SAYS BIDEN IS THE GUY.
GET IN LINE.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE OBAMA WILL
DO THAT.
>> TAKE A LOOK AT PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
HE IS SAYING THAT HE IS NOT THE
GUY THAT OBAMA WAS TALKING TO
FOR THIS ANONYMOUS QUOTE.
>> I AM NOT.
OUR MESSAGE IS RESONATING HERE.
I THINK IOWANS ARE LOOKING FOR A
BOLD VISION AND A READIYNESS TO
DO THAT IN A WAY THAT UNIFIES
AND DOESN'T DIVIDE.
>> GREG, COUNTER MY SENTENCE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
FLORIDA.
HE IS ADVERTISING THIS IS A
HOMECOMING RALLY BECAUSE HE
MOVED FROM NEW YORK TO FLORIDA.
I AM THINKING TO MYSELF 2
THINGS.
ONE, I AM THINKING HEY, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY INCOME TAXES
IN FLORIDA, RIGHT?
AND THE SECOND THING, HE GETS TO
GO HOME EARLY FOR THANKSGIVING
WHILE I AM WORKING.
>> THERE YOU GO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS FUNNY.
YOU FOLLOWED UP BUTTIGIEG WITH
THE TALK ABOUT A RALLY.
THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE.
THE DEMs ARE SUFFERING FROM FUN
ENVY.
THE DEMOCRATIC FACES.
BIDEN, BERNIE AND BLOOMIE.
IT'S LIKE THE GOLDEN GIRLS
WITHOUT THE SEX APPEAL AND YOU
HAVE BUTTIGIEG WHO IS BORING AS
ALL HELL.
IT'S LIKE THE DMV, VERSUS DELTA
HOUSE.
A GROUP OF PEOPLE HAVING THE
TIME OF THEIR LIVES AND THEN
PEOPLE JUST SAD ALL THE TIME.
POOR JOE.
I FEEL BAD FOR JOE.
HE IS LIKE THE KIDDING WAITING
FOR HIS BROTHER TO PICK HIM UP
FROM SCHOOL AND IT'S 7 O'CLOCK
AND HE FORGOT.
IF OBAMA WERE A GOOD FRIEND, HE
WOULD PULL JOE ASIDE AND SAY YOU
HAVE TO MOVE ON.
SHE IS NOT INTO.
YOU KEEP BUYING HER FLOWERS BUT
HE IS DATING SOMEBODY ELSE.
THE GUY IS TRUMP.
AND BLOOMIE'S AD HAD THE ENERGY
OF A NAP.
LET'S GET IT ON.
NO, LET'S GO TO SLEEP.
>> WHAT IS THE DELTA HOUSE?
>> THAT WAS FROM ANIMAL HOUSE.
>> I THOUGHT THERE WAS A DELTA
LOUNGE I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> DID YOU SEE ANIMAL HOUSE?
>> YES.
>> THERE IS A TV SHOW CALLED
DELTA HOUSE THAT WAS A SPIN OFF
OF ANIMAL HOUSE.
>> FOR ALL OF THE BAD THINGS YOU
SAY ABOUT BIDEN, HE CONTINUES TO
LEAD.
>> BECAUSE HE IS ACTUALLY KIND
OF A GOOD PERSON.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ROBERT
DENIRO TALKING ABOUT MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG.
>> I LIKE BLOOMBERG.
HE IS AN ADULT.
HE IS A GROWNUP.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WE JUST HAVE TO GET PAST THIS
GET OVER THE HUMP INTO CALM
WATERS.
BLOOMBERG MIGHT BE THE ONE.
>> WOW.
PEOPLE SAY HE IS FAR LEFT.
NOW APPARENTLY ENDORSING
BLOOMBERG.
>> THAT'S MORE OF AN INDICATION
OF THE LOS ANGELES AND NEW YORK,
COASTAL APPROACH TO THE
CAMPAIGNS AND IGNORES THE
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY.
WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT
BLOOMBERG IS THAT FOR ALL OF THE
MEASURED SUCCESS PEOPLE CITE
WITH HIM, IT'S NEVER HIMSELF HE
IS SELLING.
HE WAS NEVER THE COMMODITY.
HE WAS BANKROLLING SOMEONE ELSE.
ALL OF THE ISSUES HE MADE A
DIFFERENCEA.
-- DIFFERENCE WITH.
THAT WAS HIS MONEY BUT NOT HIM.
WE HAVE YET TO HEAR HOW HIS
MESSAGE WILL BE.
I WILL SAVE THE DEMOCRATS.
AND SECONDLY WHETHER THAT WILL
EVEN WORK.
I THINK BIDEN CAME OUT WITH A
MEASURE OF HUBEROUS THAT NO ONE
EXPECTED.
HE THOUGHT HE WOULD HAVE OBAMA'S
SUPPORT.
OBAMA ALWAYS WAS LIKE 3 TIMES
NOT A CHARM.
HE IS PROBABLY LEARNING LATE IN
THE GAME THAT THIS WAS A LIKELY
MISTAKE.
>> I HEARD TODAY DEMOCRATS
SAYING BLOOMBERG DEPORTE
SAYING BLOOMBERG SUPORTE
SAYING BLOOMBERG SUPPRTE
SAYING BLOOMBERG SUPPORE
SAYING BLOOMBERG SUPPORTED A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS.
TALKED ABOUT RUDY GIULIANI AND
GAVE MONEY TO ORRIN HATCH.
>> NOW DEMOCRATS ARE MAD AT HIM.
>> THAT'S WHAT I AM SAYING.
WAIT A SECOND YOU ARE WAITING
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
>> HE IS NOT REALLY RUNNING.
HE IS RUNNING ADS TO CRUSH
TRUMP.
THIS IS NOT A SISTER.
CONSPIRACY.
IT'S A THEORY AND I HAVE NEVER
BEEN WRONG.